they're living together in the u.s. and
that's where this family wants to stay
for legal and security reasons they
don't want to reveal where they are or
what their surname is the daughter
Heather was born in the US and so is an
American citizen her mum and dad though
are from Mexico they've lived in the US
for 11 years without valid immigration
papers
yamaneika quitter at me I'm taking care
of my daughter the only one who is
working as my husband she works in
construction I may have to take care of
my daughter because I don't have any
relatives who I trust enough to help me
a family torn between two worlds at home
they all speak Spanish on their
television set Latin American TV series
but the parents have no intention of
ever going back to Mexico their daughter
they believe has a chance of a better
life than their own if they stay north
of the border but since Donald Trump's
election the mother has been worrying
about the future I've always been afraid
of being deported
we undocumented parents fear deportation
because we must live in the shadows for
my daughter because if I get deported
she will have no I'm terrified because I
don't know who would help my daughter
grow up it says name a yet more
difficult in por que no se a Manos I
came back at her 8 year old Heather
likes to cook she's one of the best
students at school her teacher talked to
her class about the possible
consequences of the presidential
election but Heather doesn't understand
why she might have to leave her home
she's never met her grandparents in
Mexico because without papers her
parents can't travel
when a yo quisieron Reforma migratory I
I want to reform of the immigration so
that we can get American citizenship but
Bo get over it visit the grandparents in
Mexico you know you're given tank there
my daughter would know what it means to
be loved by people who she's not yet met
there are thousands of families like
Heather's in the u.s. awaiting the Trump
presidency with bated breath